from The New York Times Jenna Ellis
former Trump lawyer pleads guilty in
Georgia election case three lawyers
indied with Trump for trying to uh three
lawyers ined with Donald Trump for
trying to overturn the 2020 election
results will now cooperate with
prosecutors in the racketeering case I
believe this makes four guilty pleas and
Sydney pow got six years in Pro of
Probation and then the other three got
five years Jen Alis gets got five years
I believe she also got 100 hours of
community service and pay fine and pay a
fine we have the here I'm going to play
it for you let's uh yeah we're going to
listen to what she had to say audio is
good
yep thank you honor for the opportunity
to address the
court as an attorney who is also a
Christian I take my responsibilities as
a lawyer very seriously and I Endeavor
to be a person of sound moral and
ethical character in all of my dealings
in the wake of the 2020 presidential
election I believe that challenging the
results on behalf of President Trump
should be pursued in a just and legal
way I endeavored to represent my client
to the best of my ability I relied on
others including lawyers with many more
years of experience than I to provide me
with true and reliable information
especially since my role involved
speaking to the media and to legislators
in various States what I did not do but
should have done your honor was to make
sure that the facts the other lawyers
alleged to be true were in fact true in
the frenetic pace of attempting to raise
challenges to the election in several
States including Georgia I failed to do
my due diligence I believe in and I
value election Integrity if I knew then
what I know now I would have declined to
represent Donald Trump in these
post-election challenges I look back on
this whole experience with deep remorse
for those failures of mind your honor I
have taken responsibility already before
the Colorado bar who censured me and I
now take responsibility before this
court and apologize to the people
so uh I I hope I hope several other
states file criminal charges against her
and she goes to prison for a very very
long time did you hear what she said she
she confessed to trying to uh overturn
an election a du a duly elected Joe
Biden she confessed to doing it no in
all seriousness um I think it's fair to
say she's opened the door legally by
stating that in Georgia and many other
states she did this she did this thing
and if there are States in which
Democrats have any kind of uh legal
capability they could charge her as well
and then make her go through it all over
again the biggest mistake all of these
people are making in my opinion is
taking the plea deals I've heard a lot
of people say the cases against these
individuals in Georgia is so weak that
the prosecutors didn't want to go to
trial and I'm like then you go to trial
then you say that's the reason to do
that yeah this shows she was terrified
and so I'll say this just on the service
if it is true that she and many others
knowingly lied to commit this crime then
I think they're getting off easy
otherwise she genuinely believed she was
doing her her constitutional Duty in
providing a legal service uh uh to an
individual who's seeking a Regis of
Grievances and now she is betraying not
just that individual but this country so
in that case lock her up see if I care
she'll get she'll get no defense from me
and not to mention I we'll get into it
in a little bit but like the hundreds of
thousands of dollars she raised a lot of
people are really upset about this you
know what does it mean to give someone's
legal defense she paid her lawyers with
the money does it mean she's taking it
all the way some people were saying she
should take a plea agreement but I'm
curious uh what you think man I mean you
worked in the administration yeah look
as was a prosecutor as a public defender
um the interesting thing about this
entire case I mean put aside the fact
that I don't think there's a basis to
bring it but let's put that on pause for
a second and the first three guys out of
the gate that flipped are lawyers and
what does that mean what did they
actually do do having been in the Trump
Administration and around the boss and
literally talking to him every week
these guys didn't really do anything so
okay what are they going to say are they
going to break attorney client privilege
which they don't hold president Trump
holds and say and commit a felony and
get disbarred and get prosecuted just to
say Donald Trump is guilty of xwi Z and
they're not stupid people I think the
reason they pled guilty is they know the
crimes are bogus but they came in there
with so many slews of felonies so it's
like oh you're looking at 85 years we'll
get you on one and this jury pool sucks
it's in somewhere in Georgia that is a
county that is like 88% Pro Biden so
they're going to get convicted so
they're just trying to stay out of jail
pleading to misdemeanors but I would
really like to you know and I also
looked at no no that's a felony I'm
pretty sure Jenna El was a she pled it
guilty to a felony I'm pretty sure it
was a felony and and I and I cuz I was
reading it and I thought it was uh cuz
Sydney pal was like six misdemeanor and
they they dropped all she the first one
to go though I mean they gave her the
best deal yeah I I I want to check
because the story I was reading earlier
I'm pretty sure she was the one that was
a single felony which was uh I thought
was interesting yep yep yep she pleaded
guilty to a felony charge so no more
traveling outside the country luck it's
it's one count of aiding and abetting
false statements and writing and
writings for like stuff she said to the
Georgia no no if you commit a felony and
it's in the favor of the democratic
party like Kevin Klein Smith the FBI
attorney who lied to the federal court
about CIA documents he got reinstated to
the bar last year and has a seven fig
job now well he's more trustworthy so
this is coming along with her book deal
and her tell all and I think it's part
of the process it's why you heard from
that White House intern who made her her
lies and launched her bogus book but
this is what they do the media captures
him and says we're going to launch you
to you know part of me says I don't
blame any one of these individuals for
taking the deal because they all took
the deal right it is a sign of the
weakness of the anti-establishment
faction in this country that they don't
actually stand up for anything and then
you look at uh uh we talked about this
this uh famous makeup artist whatever
her name was you know uh her line is
Huda Beauty I can't remember her last
name she posts in favor of Palestine
gets a whole bunch of backlash and she
say I don't care don't buy my products I
stand for what I believe in I'm like man
okay I mean these these These leftists
are willing to just sacrifice everything
for like their business their company
their money you've got you've got the
whole bunch of reports of people getting
fired from their jobs they don't care
it's always been this way I mentioned
this with BLM the guy worked at Taco
Bell put on a BLM coid mask and they
said you can't wear that and he goes I
refuse to take it off and they said if
you don't take it off you're fired he
goes fine goes outside films a video and
says I got fired for black lives matter
and then the company apologized oh we're
so sorry what do people on the right do
they take a plea deal what did Jenna
Ellis do she was a lawyer who was
approached by a client who says here's
my argument can you draft this for me
and she goes oh yeah we'll go through it
and we'll advise you on it and that was
it she was she was she had one count
under Rico and one count of I believe
soliciting a public official or
something like that two two charges is
what she was facing and she took a
felony plea deal hundreds of thousand
dollars and is crying what I what I
genuinely believe is that Jenna Ellis
legitimately thought she was
representing her client in 2020 and is
now terrified and would rather sell you
out you out all of us out in this
country so that she can disappear this
is a part of like this is an established
practice if you in Trump World and
you're in Trump orbit and you get
jettison for not doing your job properly
there not only is it a Scarlet Letter
it's an act of Vengeance look at the the
gal that's on the uh not the Today's
Show but the view right that's one
example the other intern that wrote The
White House book as long as you get
jettison from Trump World and are
willing to play ball I guarantee you
every one of these people has a book
deal lined up has a show lined up and is
now guaranteed not to go to prison and
like you said they don't have any morals
they don't have any convictions all they
have to do is just say what they want
and they're going to be famous they're
going to go to Hollywood and la and
people are going to put them on their
shows and they're going to be the
greatest saviors of America if if Sydney
Powell of all people Michael Flynn's
attorney I got to remind your audience
Sydney Powell was Michael Flynn's
attorney who helped overturn that case
and and and if if if she of all people
will flip on Trump why would anyone Hold
the Line yeah they they they just
watched It's like being on the
battlefield and watching George
Washington drop his pants and cry and
run from the battlefield I I shouldn't
compare her to George Washington but I'm
saying like a bunch of regular people
are watching Sydney pow go on TV and
scream and bang her fist and say I will
not back down the viral video of her
saying I will not be intimidated and
then as soon as they're like we're
criminally charging you starts crying
she's like please I'll do anything you
say this is a woman who was one of the
people smiling in her mug shot right she
presented
this yeah she presented this this uh
intensity
uh to an extreme degree how can we have
a country where we're saying you know
we're anti-establishment you've got to
confront the values here you have to
stick by these things and then you have
these uh people immediately try I mean
obviously it's what the Democrats want
but in some ways to me it really foils
the motion that Trump filed today in his
January 6 case saying you know you
should dis dismiss the case because of
First Amendment and d double jeopardy
but one of the lines in the case was
under the First Amendment Trump and his
supporters have the right to question
and doubt what the government tells them
and so this idea that like she knowingly
proom promoted false information number
one did she know it was wrong and under
the First Amendment doesn't she have the
right to doubt it I mean it is sad to
see someone who could have argued a
really articulate message in court take
the plea deal I understand that there's
pressure on the other hand if we're a
values-based movement you need people
who are willing to defend their values
the bravado is always so much more so
online than it is in the real world but
also like you said like for somebody
like you were talking about the makeup
uh she was a makeup distributor right
she's signaling to her base who's going
to support her anyways but when somebody
who anti-establishment on the right is
pushing back they feel a lot of the
times like they're out on a life raft
once they actually put themselves out
there like that because where is there
to go if it all falls through and they
start coming at you with criminal
charges that you do have to you know
especially if they have a family if they
have kids and stuff like that they're
thinking about what that's going to
happen I'm not saying that's right wrong
I'm just saying I understand where the
mindset comes from where at the end of
the day a lot of these people are going
to put themselves and their loved ones
first over the movement because that's
just hierarchy of needs right for a lot
of them I think this is a direct result
of the two-tier system of justice that's
been built in this country it's one of
my biggest grievances in government
gangsters and it's not just in federal
court it's in state court and what Tim
said was they flipped that's the key for
me as a for okay what did they flip on
but what they're doing is they're going
out to the New York Times and saying oh
we got Trump's three top lawyers and as
a guy from Trump World I'm telling you
these people barely did anything for the
boss and he came out and announced that
Sydney pal wasn't even his attorney so
what they're doing though publicly is
they're saying three Trump lawyers have
now pled guilty to the election fraud
scam case L run by Donald Trump they're
trying it in the public they're trying
to get more and more dominoes to fall so
that when Trump gets the court in in
Georgia finally whenever that is they're
going to say oh 14 defendants have pled
guilty you must be guilty by association
where there's smoke there's fire must be
but where's the evidence because if they
had it this is the thing about you know
about the New York Times and these
corrupt prosecutors if they had a
recording if they had you know the I got
you moment the kill shot it would have
leaked this is the evidence that's what
I'm saying they begin filing 14th
Amendment challenges to Donald Trump's
2024 candidacy they're going to say the
court judge say what's your evidence
Jenna Allison City pile confessed we
have confessions your honor we have
several I mean if they hadn't to your
point if they had theole they wouldn't
offer The Plea Deals they would want
every single person to go down for as
long no yeah as a prosecutor I was like
I don't want to you're not going down
for 5 years you're going away for 40 but
it me they don't have anything right
your what was the maximum TR like if she
had been if she had gone to court and
tried her luck what was the maximum
sentence she would have gotten I think
it's probably 20 years because it's a
RICO conspiracy so would they would they
would they would all the sentences be
concurrent not no it's up to the judge
yeah not at all like you could stack
them you can hold she had two she had
two two charges so Rico and you can make
him consecutive um so it's a it's a
total crap Sho but that 14th Amendment
thing this is just another like
hysterical thing has anyone read the
first sentence of the 14th Amendment I
know you guys have but it says these
individuals shall not and it names the
vice president the Senators the members
of the House of Representative in lower
level offices you know who doesn't name
the presidency the 14th amendment by its
first sentence doesn't apply to the
presidency and we have all these
freaking lawsuits around the country
trying to disbar or whatever the word is
get Donald Trump off the ballot which is
hilarious and this boondoggle in
Colorado I think just uh forwarded the
case on to say oh this issue is ripe for
uh decision-making because people are
talking about it publicly thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net